buenas tardes
bueno yo quiero preguntarles a ustedes
aquí quien cree que la educación es el
medio para transformar el mundo
qué chévere yo también lo creo y estoy
convencida que nuestro país va a mejorar
si trabajamos en educación pero trabajar
en educación en colombia se nos
convierte un poquito algo retador cuando
en el último estudio de la ocde por
ejemplo nos dicen que una familia puede
salir de la pobreza después de 11
generaciones
convirtiéndonos en el país más desigual
de la región
y esta desigualdad se ve totalmente
impactada en la educación entonces
cuando uno dice cómo va a trabajar en
educación trabajo en infraestructura
trabajo en cobertura trabajo en
deserción en que trabajo
y en seguida toda esta desigualdad me
impacta cuando me hacen unos exámenes
internacionales a los estudiantes y por
ejemplo empieza 2015
piso en el año 2015 reviso
analizo los estudiantes qué habilidades
tenían para resolver problemas a través
del trabajo en equipo y tenemos el
resultado que el 62 por ciento de
nuestros estudiantes no tienen esa
habilidad
entonces
uno mira esto y dice bueno hay que
trabajar en educación pero por donde
empezamos un día esta mujer estaba
buscando trabajo cuando se grababa
derecho y encontró una publicidad con
este aviso un día todos los niños y
jóvenes en colombia tengan la
oportunidad de recibir educación de
calidad
me gustó y al ladito decía y tú puedes
hacer parte de esto vinculante
y lo primero que yo hice fue bueno pero
porque la educación es importante para
mí porque yo creo en la educación y esto
me llevo a dos espacios muy importantes
en mi vida
y el primer espacio fue mi familia
mi familia es la típica familia
colombiana la familia que las abuelas no
tengo la oportunidad de acabar el
colegio
y de ahí para allá al impacto estuvo en
los tíos y los papás
mis papás son dos seres totalmente
maravillosos que al inicio de mi vida no
tuvimos los recursos económicos que todo
el mundo sueña
pero ellos me mostraron como con estos
recursos económicos me dan la educación
de calidad que podían darme porque es un
detalle muy importante aquí en colombia
la educación de calidad cuesta no todos
podemos acceder a educación de calidad
porque tiene un precio y ciertos grupos
privilegiados podemos estar allí
entonces el segundo espacio fue mi
carrera cuando yo estaba en mi carrera
era abogada
de personas que habían sido víctimas de
delitos contra su integridad sexual
libertad personal y de vida y los casos
que me llegaban era que de 50 casos 45
casos eran de personas que no habían
acabado el colegio
tanto la víctima como el victimario
entonces yo dije bueno si la educación
vale la pena cómo lo vamos a hacer pues
la apuesta era ser docente por dos años
en colegios de situación vulnerable
entonces la doctora lorena pasó a ser la
señora lorena
la señora lorena fue a dictar clase a
barranquilla
entonces lo primero que me causó esta
decisión fue el impacto que tenía en mí
eso de ser profesor es facilísimo dos
años regalados pasan rápido los niños
les leo cuento les transformó la vida
y segundo el impacto que tenían mis
conocidos
lorena tu estudiaste cinco años en la
universidad para hacer ahora y te vas a
volver profesor
vas a perder la plata de tu carrera
y yo guau tanto mi círculo social como
yo es meditamos la labor docente
esta foto fue tomada cuatro meses
después de ser profesora porque mi
primer mes fue caos
sobre todos los días
porque no sabía qué hacer
tenía 45 niños a 32 grados centígrados
en un salón sin aire acondicionado
42 niños
qué
las actividades económicas de sus padres
eran
y robar a las personas que iban a bocas
de ceniza en barranquilla
vender droga o vender fritos
además de eso tenía el reto de ser mujer
bogotana en la costa
este ser humano que ustedes ven aquí no
era ese en la costa ahí estoy arreglada
entonces si yo iba a tomarme una cerveza
a la calle los hombres se sentían con la
autoridad de pedirme sexo
voy a insultarme porque una mujer
decente no toma cerveza en el
parqueadero de su casa
o era la cachaca maluca porque no quería
que mi invadieran mi privacidad cuando
me preguntaba si quería tener hijos
y aparte de eso descubrí que es ser
profesor en colombia y descubrí que hay
tres tipos de profesores
el profesor del sector público que es el
profesor secretaria de educación que
tiene un cargo fijo servidor público el
profesor de colegio privado de colegio
de élite que tiene unas muy buenas
alternativas y los estudiantes son muy
buenos y los profesores de colegio
privado clase media-baja
el profe privado que tiene un salario
cero competitivo dice cuentas un día y
para recuperarlo en mi carrera me
gastaba ocho años trabajando siendo
docente
tenía 20 minutos de almuerzo y trabaja 8
horas
y todos los días lloraba ya nadie le
importaba
este lugar me destruyó
y creo que hoy en día me enseñó muchas
cosas por ejemplo a medirme cuando para
cuando tú no puedes hacer algo
y cuando tienes que renunciar
eso fue barranquilla el primer año de
profesora
no cometas la bogotá
en bogotá tengo otro reto digamos que
mis niños no tenían todos estos retos
que habían en barranquilla era profe de
niños de grado 11 y la apuesta con ellos
fue sensibilizar acerca del conflicto
armado colombiano en mi país
porque en bogotá mis niños decían yo no
soy víctima del conflicto a mí eso nunca
me pasó
y le apostamos a enseñar ciencias
sociales a través de la metodología de
la memoria histórica que fue un
reconocimiento de nuestra identidad
cuerpo emociones para poder empatizar
con todos los actores del conflicto
militares
y actores armados ilegales y sobre todo
nuestras víctimas
el proyecto fue todo un éxito lo que les
puedo decir es la cosa más feliz que me
ha pasado en la vida es el lanzamiento
de la feria del libro eso fue una
publicación que me hizo una niña un año
después de ser profesora y dónde los
encuentro y me abrazan me llaman a decir
ve feliz cumpleaños profe lorena yo
quiero ser como usted bueno
por dichos irradiar de felicidad
pero luego mi siguiente trabajo allá yo
irradiaba tanta felicidad y dije no pues
a mí no me importa viajar dos horas al
colegio no me importa ganarme un poquito
conozcamos a mis colegas
y comencé a socializar con los profes
la profe gloria
la que está al lado derecho
es una profe que lleva haciendo 20 años
profesora
y es el hit
enseña matemáticas el hit y yo le
pregunté
venga profe me enseña cómo hace ustedes
y comenzó a enseñarme unas técnicas de
aprendizaje cooperativo
y un momento a otro me mira y me dice
lorena le puedo decir una cosa y yo sí
señora cuénteme usted que va a ser el
otro año yo no no tengo ni idea
posiblemente voy a hacer una desempleada
más del país porque se acaban estos dos
años me dices y váyase del colegio
usted es demasiado talentosa y demasiado
buena para que se quede aquí
a mí esto me causó tanta curiosidad que
fue pero porque me está diciendo esto
una señora que le pone el alma a la
educación
y comencé a indagar cositas pequeñas con
los profesores y les decía venga profe
este estudio después de la universidad y
me decían lorena por favor usted sabe
cómo nos toca aquí
usted tiene que calificar 280 trabajos
pegarse 4 horas de transporte y usted
está diciendo que sí voy a hacer una
maestría y segundo que tiene plata para
hacerse una maestría con este salario
pues no no la hay y yo a tiene sentido
y comenzaba a ver a profes poco
inspirados
entonces un día me reuní con una amiga
que estábamos viviendo los idilios y la
felicidad de ser docentes dijimos [ __ ]
que hacemos para que los profesores van
a sentir inspirados usted porque se
siente feliz levantándose a las 4 y 50
de la mañana entonces comenzamos a hacer
primero cuentas cuál es la vida de un
profesor y estará mi vida cuando era
profesora en bogotá
las tareas de un maestro en la semana es
lo que oficialmente dice mi contrato de
trabajo
tengo 26 horas de clase una hora
dirección de curso una hora atención a
padres una hora institucional y seis
horas de refuerzo escolar
y estos son mis tareas generales dejó
planear clases porque si mis clases
fueron un éxito y mis estudiantes
comprendieron porque el conflicto armado
trasciende sus vidas fue porque yo me
gastaba de una hora y media planeando
clases y tenía ocho clases a la semana
multipliquemos tiene que calificar
trabajos de 280 estudiantes
tenía que escuchar las crisis de los
estudiantes pues sí y si a un estudiante
le termina el novio se le acabó la vida
se muchachito se la acabó entonces a uno
le toca ir a decirle sí mi amor
tranquilo todo va a pasar llenar
observadores llevar las asistencias y
otras sino suma y para todo en 55 horas
y yo me la pasada 40 horas en el colegio
y mientras me levantaba a las 4 y 50 y
llegaba a las cinco y cincuenta mi casa
nunca veía a mi familia no tenía novio
no tenía amigos mi vida eran los niños y
efectivamente esa era la vida de un
viernes al ir a un museo me quedaba a
dormir
entonces lo primero que descubrimos fue
el principal impacto que tiene un profe
es cuando planea su clase y en su salón
de clase tiene el contacto con este
estudiante y le transforma la vida
cuando el estudiante siente que hace
profesor le importa
entonces dijimos con una amiga
creemos pasos para enseñar
y que es pasos para enseñar pasos para
enseñar es una metodología que nos
creamos mi amiga carla y yo que las dos
somos abogadas siendo profesoras sin
tener vida
dijimos como planeamos las clases
nosotros entonces cojamos el currículo
estos profes
te mola en la metodología y planeamos
las más clases pero que ellos también
puedan ponerles esa esencia que tiene el
profesor porque efectivamente todos los
profesores son diferentes entonces la
idea de pasos es eso
passos se adapta al profe no el profe se
adapta pasos porque ese es otro problema
que llega acá en educación mil
metodologías pero usted adapte se haga
que se abre pero no tengo tiempo
entonces todo sale mal
passos cree 100% en esta premisa la
educación de buena calidad impartida por
docentes competentes y bien respaldados
es un derecho de todos los niños jóvenes
y adultos y no el privilegio de unos
pocos el niño de voz a barranquilla el
txoko merece tener un profesor de
calidad
[Aplausos]
passos es una iniciativa 100% de ocio de
personas que creen en la educación que
empezó con carla y con lorena y se le
han ido sumando personas
juan josé y sacha son los artistas
stefan y nos ayudó a buscar
patrocinadores maría lisa es psicóloga
con intervención social entonces toda
nuestra metodología está a partir de la
ética del cuidado las emociones en el
aula de clase cuando ave trabaja en
temas de memoria cultura y glenn y los
promociona y en las redes sociales
passos entiende que la educación
necesita humanidad la educación no
necesita cifras
paso se entiende que uno cuando recibe
esto en su instagram que a un niño de 16
años le pregunté cómo sería mi profesor
ideal diga que sea lorena lópez
necesitamos que todos los profes se
sientan inspirados y que ellos digan que
su profesor ideal es su profesor de
química de matemáticas de sociales
necesitamos volver a educarlos un día yo
embarranque ya estuve destruida y
frustrada
pero era porque los papás de mis
estudiantes no habían recibido educación
y actualmente vivo en choco vivo en
quibdó chocó
dónde soy discriminada por ser de bogotá
y por ser mujer
[Música]
a veces me duele
a veces me quiero ir y quiero renunciar
pero luego recuerdo
es que la mitad de la población de choco
no recibe educación de calidad y que son
víctimas de una violencia estructural
entonces mi invitación hoy es
educar es transformar y obviamente la
herramienta más poderosa que tenemos
porque si así como un día transformó a
mi familia me transformó a mí
todos nos merecemos tener
pero necesita humanidad y necesita
reconocimiento de un actor y un
protagonista no solo son los niños los
niños son efectivamente el foco
pero los maestros son los que están ahí
y un maestro sin humanidad no va a
dictar buenas clases entonces hoy y
siempre vengo haciendo esta campaña
ponete a la campaña a abrazar a una
maestra a un maestro estresado para
mejorar la educación gracias
[Aplausos]